our lives are so busy it's ridiculous I
mean people can't believe it when they
see our schedule not only are we filming
up to three of our shows at the time we
also try to have a personal life I'm
getting married this spring so it's
tough hold it
breathing break go game back a lot has
changed for these twins who made their
TV debut in 2011 meet drew and Jonathan
Scott the property brothers we think
alike we have the same sense of humor
and we're both very driven and we love
helping people and so in all aspects of
our life that's really helped us to
believe and it makes things better -
with the families we work with because
you always want to have one
better-looking twin and so I fill those
shoes and I feel them well I'm
better-looking he has the better looking
it was like his lioness main hippos
stopped me in the street random men
women everything stopped in street just
say you have amazing hair
that was my surfer look well some trends
come and go one thing's for sure these
brothers have built an empire in fact
they made half a billion dollars last
year alone you guys are big stars around
the world these are like moving you're a
busy very busy very very busy I mean we
air in over 150 countries now and so no
matter where we go people stop us and
I'm glad if I can inspire people oh well
the great thing is drew can name off
every single one of those hundred fifty
came from multiple TV shows to an Emmy
nomination in 2015 it's an honor to have
people nominated nanami us this year to
a home product line books and their own
home renovations
welcome to the Scott family home we feel
pretty lucky to have come along for the
ride
gonna fund your journey has been a busy
journey but it's it is kind of a while I
wake up sometimes I think wow we're
really doing what we wanted to do I mean
I personally say we couldn't do all this
without you to Canada
but no matter how busy these brothers
are they know how to have fun with
Suisse offers had when they invited us
to their fan cruise we're setting sail
on the first-ever ultimate design cruise
sailing with the Scott and all the epeak
and invited along for the ride let's get
to the fun and just when you think
they've done it all
well they decide to become country
singers
so we're coming
you also are you know quite musically
inclined if I do say so myself so excuse
me what what's that
would you drop hold on Billboard you
drop the Billboard chart yeah so it's
really no surprise they were also named
as one of People magazine's sexiest men
alive in 2013 and 2018 and were also
featured in Hello magazine in Canada's
most beautiful issue well I think it
takes two of us to actually create one
beautiful Canadian he'll use his hair
maybe his beard my my pectorals his but
I thought it would actually get me a
date and it has not so come on what do I
gotta do Jonathan needs to hit him up on
Twitter and even though these two are
attached at the hip drew decided to try
something on his own by becoming a
contestant on Dancing with the Stars in
2017 I'm consistently amazed by how well
you're doing and what you keep bringing
to the show every must say you were the
first person to ever say that I have
moves because aside from you at the bar
like yeah this has been more
entertaining for me having my Dancing
with the Stars because I've never saw
him at our high school prom and that was
not when in a mirror ball so this is
exciting and in 2018 we sat down with
Drew and his fiancee Linda right before
they tied the knot who's most likely to
cry during the vows
oh that I I am the first one to admit I
will be a babbling fool which is walking
up looking beautiful in her wedding gown
yeah I will be signaling but putting a
ring on it isn't keeping these brothers
from teaming up again for their new
series property brothers forever home
this is the cabin side grew up with I
just don't want to smash them give me a
hug
we're gonna make this kitchen even more
beautiful and we're gonna make sure you
make lots more memories in it thank you
because I'm not touring new houses for
them to buy I'm more hands-on again on
the construction side like we used to be
back in finally yeah we got drew doing
the work again my manager